I hope that you're following me on
instagram i'm on instagram at david dot
pakman and i had some pictures over the
Thanksgiving break that a lot of people
found compelling and interesting that i
want to share with you first and
foremost i was watching my dad's dog for
a couple of days during the Thanksgiving
break he is a roughly 70 pound black
english lab so similar to an American
lab sort of stockier bigger head uh sort
of thicker arms and legs I guess you
would say uh and an incredibly difficult
and needy dog and he participated in
some of the Facebook live streams that I
did during the Thanksgiving break and uh
so so so some of the Facebook live
audience got to see him very difficult
dog incredibly food oriented and I know
generally Pat that labs are very food
oriented but this is I mean it's like
nothing I've ever seen before great dog
I mean the best personality but uh it's
so food oriented in needy and we know
that David is a dog person type
according to a past conversation yes
indeed and uh even even my dad's dog uh
is not thrilled with cats like the
neighbor's cat uh sort of appeared
outside of the back window at one point
and Nemo was not thrilled with the
appearance of that cat so that the dog
and I do share in common but one of the
just amazing you should see I mean just
does not care about doing anything you
demand of him ask of him i think is the
right word if you don't have food in
your hands you could take a cucumber
slice i mean anything even foods that
dogs don't usually care about and you
have his attention like nothing else i
mean it is like uh you know adderall dog
where his focus is just so intense even
with just a scrap of a vegetable
anything uh it's like two different dogs
if your food in your hands yeah i mean
dogs don't tend to have the greatest of
aspirations but i'm sure you can always
encourage him with a little bit of a
treat in your pocket or something yep no
doubt about it also popular from over
the Thanksgiving break on my Instagram
account me getting a fire going and you
know that there's people who will
complain about everything I put this
picture up of me get
a fire going and this was sort of early
in the fire process and most people like
it oh it's great you know whoa Western
Massachusetts its fall blah blah blah
blah blah and then people start telling
me how it's really bad actually to do
fires for the environment sending a link
to a sam Harris article were Sam
explains that people have this romantic
idea of the campfire and that actually
the smoke that comes off of the wood is
as bad or worse for you than cigarettes
which if if true is absolutely horrible
Pat but what I've learned of by being on
instagram at david dot pakman is that no
matter what I do no matter what I post
somebody will be very upset about it who
knew that you're offending so many
people I was not aware my yeah just
casual Instagram pictures offend people
please follow me on there david pakman
uh a lot of behind-the-scenes stuff from
the studio also on instagram